Ladies and gentlemen, we got him one of the
biggest stories for sure of the last three
months, if not the last three years.
The New York Times has obtained Donald Trump's
tax return data extending over more than two
decades.
The contents of the tax information is absolutely
stunning.
Is it devastating to Trump?
I don't know.
I don't know that his followers care about
anything at this point.
We will talk about that.
But this is much of.
But not all.
Much of what many have been waiting for for
years.
Donald Trump's tax returns, which he set in
2015, once he's no longer under audit, he
would release whatever happened to that.
We know that he was just lying.
Well, they are now out.
Some of the revelations include Donald Trump
paid a total of seven hundred and fifty dollars
in federal income taxes the year that he won
the presidency.
Seven hundred and fifty dollars total in his
first year in the White House.
His total federal tax payments were seven
hundred and fifty dollars.
He paid no federal income taxes at all in
10 of the previous 15 years.
None.
How much did you pay?
How much did I pay?
If I showed you the amount of federal tax
I paid and the amount Trump paid, you would
assume I made way more money than Donald Trump
in these years.
This entire decade long audit battle with
the Internal Revenue Service has been exposed
as being over the legitimacy of a nearly 73
million dollar tax refund that Donald Trump
claimed.
Understand that Donald Trump filed taxes,
claiming he was entitled to seventy two point
nine million dollars of a tax refund.
He received that tax refund and that is now
being investigated.
Donald Trump may have stolen 73 million dollars
from you, for me, from whoever else actually
paid taxes.
And if indeed that was an inappropriate refund
that he claimed, he may be on the hook for
one hundred million dollars once you account
for the fees and fines on top of all of this.
The documents do confirm that Donald Trump
has been overstating his business strength
in 2018 as an example.
Donald Trump disclosed in a financial disclosure,
which is not a legal document, that he made
four hundred thirty five million dollars.
The tax records say he lost 47 million dollars.
Now, of course, if you want to seem rich,
but save on taxes, you would disclose a lot
of money and you would argue for tax purposes
you lost money.
This is a gap of more than five hundred million
dollars.
And it is connected to all of these other
very clear instances of Donald Trump claiming
that people need to PR.
They pay their fair share.
Donald Trump's tweets, About half of Americans
pay no federal tax are a little low because
they don't produce anything.
Trump's the one barely paying federal taxes.
Every single thing we thought Trump might
be hiding.
He's hiding.
We said, you know, Trump might be hiding,
that he's paying very little in taxes despite
being a super rich dude.
That is exactly right.
We said, you know, Trump might be hiding,
that his businesses aren't really doing so
well.
He's not as wealthy as he wants people to
think.
And that is exactly right.
We said he might owe people a ton of money,
making him a good target.
And that is exactly right.
The documents that The New York Times has
obtained showed that Donald Trump has three
hundred million dollars in loans, which he
is personally responsible for.
They come due in the next few years.
If Trump is reelected, we will have a president
who owes 300 million dollars and has to start
paying it back during his second term.
And in total, four hundred and twenty one
million dollars in debt is Donald Trump.
To whom does he owe that money?
That's a real question.
That's always, by the way, Josh Campbell,
former FBI agent, said when you vet people
for federal government jobs, if they have
a lot of debt, that is a red flag because
it makes them potentially vulnerable to being
pressured because of those debts that they
have.
Look at what Donald Trump owes.
And then, as always, with Donald Trump, there
is a tweet for everything.
Donald Trump tweeting in 2012 that quote,
Barack Obama, who wants to raise all our taxes,
only pays twenty point five percent on a 790000
dollar salary.
Do as I say, not as I do, pays 20 percent.
Trump paid zero dollars in 10 of the last
15 years.
Now, the important question in the end, because
we're 40 days from an election, we are five
weeks from an election.
The question in the end is, does this make
a difference?
Will this influence voters?
I don't know that it will.
This obviously runs completely counter to
what Donald Trump ran on.
Donald Trump ran on him for the middle class.
Donald Trump ran on.
I'm from personal responsibility.
We have too many people who pay no taxes.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Remember that during the 2016 election when
the narrative was it takes someone to know
how to play the game in order to fix it for
everybody.
That's what Trump ran on.
Okay.
Yeah.
Listen, mate.
I know how to play the game, so I'm in a fix.
It didn't quite pan out, did it?
Who would have thought that a giant beneficiary
of the system might want to maintain it?
Obviously, as we've been saying, and yet so
many people are worse off economically now
than they were when Donald Trump took office.
And Trump's the one paying seven hundred and
fifty dollars in federal taxes.
The people who will be appalled by this, though,
they're already not voting for Donald Trump.
I was already getting tweets yesterday from
people saying, dude, this is why Trump so
smart.
He hasn't paid taxes in years legally or hey,
listen, Trump's businesses lost money some
years.
So those years he shouldn't be paying taxes.
And what's hilariously hypocritical about
these overlapping rebuttals is that you've
got the same people who are saying, hey, listen,
if Trump's businesses lost money, he shouldn't
be paying taxes.
Those are the same people who say Trump's
a business genius.
Well, hold on a second.
Which one is it?
So in the end, I don't know if this is going
to move the needle.
It only needs to move the needle a little
bit.
If we can get if this story gets a few people
to vote who weren't going to, it could be
so close in some key states that it might
actually make a difference in the end.
Now, on the back end of this story, there
is an even bigger story.
There is a systemic story here which is much
bigger than Trump.
And I think that for the next 40 days, the
story is Trump and his taxes in 41 days, assuming
Joe Biden wins.
The story here is we have a tax system set
up to help the really wealthy avoid paying
taxes in mostly legal ways, although, again,
Donald Trump may have taken a 73 million dollar
refund that he didn't actually deserve.
So this is about Donald Trump, but it's also
about systemic abuse.
It's about how Warren Buffett has famously
pointed out that there are years where his
effective tax rate was lower than his secretary's.
If I recall correctly, I'm going from memory
of Warren Buffett.
Turbo billionaire Warren Buffett once said
that there was a year where his effective
tax rate was like 17 percent and his secretaries
was 21 percent.
That's really the big story here beyond Donald
Trump.
We're going to have plenty of time to deal
with that story.
But for the next 40 days, does this hurt Trump?
Let me
know what
you think.